don't come to earth and like a big
donkey and it was kind of what we
thought now I know like Kousaka madam
diesel era we pronounced I'm sure right
after the episode we did it this
probably be like a million enjoy talk op
well now I know I yes
he shoots deep he shoots he fucking he
shits missiles out his ass he's he's
half dog laughter let's not talk about
this episode and simply discuss the
awesomeness that is a dog copter in the
world
Oh three for that matter I am wondering
too was there like three dog copter
books or did they take one book and turn
this one obviously is rise of the
canines uh the segment was definitely
Judgment Day
yeah uh no judgment dog and the first
one was on Chapter judgement dog yeah
justice was just don't copter one I
actually at the one there or the first
movie yeah the fellowship of the dock
the fellowship of the dog yeah um well
then would that mean the next would be
dogcopter to the wrath of mutt as long
as there's a quickening in there that's
all that matters um I so dogcopter
amazing and I gotta say I really want to
read this book series um the song around
her book series the book is better
according to her loss of Liberty she
didn't say it was bad just that they
took some liberties um you know when
they have lost out there was somebody
reading like a screenplay because one of
the people on the plane was a writer you
know and he was reading the book tells
on there something like that and they
made the book later that you made this
book and I'm just like can we just make
dogcopter like a book series like please
yeah you don't have to make you a doctor
book you guys making that good but we'll
still buy it just the fact that it would
exist would be amazing I mean that
they're showing how to make those cat
ice-cream sandwiches and stuff I'd be as
like we need don't copter the books
um maybe exist somebody they can have
yeah somebody write three at least three
dogcopter bugs yeah um they can be
picture books for our cotton candy lion
back just like Jesus can walk on water
um I guess just like a slight I get ya
know it's a justice a just like a
science so it's we got the whole
Christian metaphor thing going um
that means Stevens a disciple I guess
would be gravy was Judas does that make
her Mary Magdalene I can't figure out
whether Louis is obviously the Virgin
Mary
maybe I mean they say that she has to
have become human to be with the father
too but we don't know how they do it who
do you say was Judas uh Steven no no
Judas has to be amethyst come on if ever
they were that's harsh
no no cuz she's all about being
mischievious and no no no no no no I
need you onion yeah yeah yeah that's we
never did no juices last night maybe
this onion Judas on amethyst could be
Peter the imperfect one pearl would be
John she's such a goody-goody I mean
bottom line there should be a religious
film made out of this is also dogcopter
and religious Steven universe uh you
know we need to make that happen uh but
but let's talk about the Hedgehog
episode um you have uh yeah him and
Connie travel to this leg we don't know
where it is
but Stevens hand seems to control kind
of like the Batcave or something like
that there's even a giant penny and uh
his mind somehow or at least the poking
of him summons these things like swords
and armor and stuff and this I guess a
training program and the lion knows all
about the lion feels has to bring him
there uh you know it did and also has a
sword in his head the lion seems to know
more than you know it lets on uh so yeah
and uh Connie uses her tennis practice
to fence uh which was pretty cool uh
you're saying I agreed had a very Zelda
feeling yes my basic groan yeah even
that mask that was firing or whatever
had an octorok kind of thing going on
yeah I kind of um that definitely had a
strong Zelda feel to write down to
reflecting the beam back and that's what
destroys it from the sword um but uh yet
what's kind of interesting there was um
something I guess I kind of relate to or
I guess I hear sometimes is that like
got you know both neither one knows why
the other kind of was to hang out with
the other cuz you know maybe he thinks
she's just you know so nice and cool and
stuff and she thinks he's like all magic
and incredible and they both think that
they're like doofuses and scrubs and
stuff so but but something is she
brought up which I've heard before is
that why I like that liner we were
Stevens like who needs magic when we
have movies like account he's like I I
wasn't saying that all like she hobbies
I got with her I'm like I'll take magic
well but something that you know the
grass is always greener I guess go we
have an uncle who's a journalist I
remember we were hanging out and this
guy's talked to a lot of people like a
lot of celebrities and musicians and
stuff like Alma Paul McCartney and uh I
pretty much named any celebrity he's
pretty much talked to him and he was
talking with his woman once
uh who was just floored by it and she's
like you know just got all I got it's
just you know my family and I at home
and stuff like that and he just said
that's that's the adventure to me is a
family you know that kids and raising a
human being and stuff like that like to
him that was the adventure and to her
the adventure was interviewing all these
people that do all this celebrity stuff
well the grass is always great so but
but it's one of those things where it's
like just don't always well me I think
this promising Johnston and we
appreciate each other for what each is
lacking
I don't think Steven has anything
resembling normal in his life and
collieries she's normal and in her case
I don't think she has anything
resembling insane magical and
adventurous and Steven is although so
and together they nearly get themselves
killed yeah um um but uh yeah I really
like this one I thought was a good mix
of what kind of like character and more
of the reveal about the backstory and
also some good laughs as well whatever
fuck all that
um yeah we got dog I hope there's more
there'd better be more sequels I dog
copter Genesis
I think em FS turning into copter
salvation uh turning into the dog copter
with the Radiohead I mean that was about
a surreal imagery yes you could
dogcopter for dogcopter Takes Manhattan
pick up a bolt feel did you get that
know like there's better oh they're like
let's do it now so yeah cat felt like
bolt o bolt itself was a spoof kind of
of Inspector Gadget so that kind of I
guess or just like yes are like spy I
always kind of felt like spy shows what
bump was making a cartoon within the
movies yeah true um so yeah uh it's
going to make dog counter they set up
again some more nice mystery of what's
going on how much does the lion know um
what can it do and what whatsit Canaries
is fjord in it sad yeah what's his
connection to Steven cuz it takes into
this place seems to have this awareness
like boughs down to have the sword take
it now and everything and knows when to
not you know like shake them off and
knows when to have them get on top and
everything which obsessed with the lion
had a sword in this head that may have
ended differently too soon my friend Oh
topical people watch his ears Leonie
fuck you probably in a week be like oh
yeah then happen yeah that sucked
or maybe not I don't know they said nice
reminder because yes I don't know how
Internet outrage work so know what I
don't I don't know what the cutoff point
is if in a week Bieber buuck the cared
about that lie and they're they already
are this will go on another six weeks
like burn I can say that this is
probably our week before it comes out so
I'm sure it'll be won't see it'll be an
interesting social experiment exactly
let's see what the turnout is um you're
watching this many years later uh some
jackass shot the wrong line but it
doesn't matter cuz you're clearly
reading dogcopter and it's changing your
life forever so um enjoy those three
books cuz we know years later that they
have to want to sell those books
door-to-door like frickin Mormons hello
have you heard the word of dog heard the
good word if dog get it yes this is a
good word of dog
so yeah um I was guessing more dogcopter
but you know what just little little
dips little over there just here and
there
ready okay yeah spread it easy just well
done dogcopter don't come too